there are 461 homes in the part of town
where Samir lives he counted that 352 of
those homes are apartments how many of
the homes are not apartments so like
always pause this video and see if you
can work through it on your own
alright now let's do this together so
we're starting with 461 homes so we have
461 and we want to know how many are not
apartments so we want to do is take out
the number that are apartments and they
tell us that 352 of those homes are
apartments so we'll take out the number
that are apartments and what we will
left it with is going to be the number
that are not apartments so we really
just have to evaluate 461 - 350 - and as
we've talked about in other videos
there's many techniques for doing this
we could break apart 352 into the
various place values so we could say
that this is the same thing as 461 - I'm
just in different colors - 3 hundreds or
300 - five tens or 50 and then minus 2
and then minus 2 right over there and
then you might be able to figure out
that 461 minus 300 that that is going to
be
I'm just taking 3 hundredths from this
so that's going to be 161 and then if I
subtract 50 from that
well what's 61 minus 50 well that would
be 11 so 161 minus 50 would be 111 or
another way of thinking about it is if
you take these five tens away from the
six tens you'll be left with 110 so that
would be 100 110 and one one so you have
111 and then you want to subtract that
to last but not least and 11 minus 2
would be 9 so 111 minus 2 would be equal
to 109 but I mentioned there's many
other ways that you might try to
approach something like this you could
say hey maybe it's easier to subtract 50
or 350 I should say then 3
fifty-two and so you could subtract two
from both of these numbers so if you
subtract two from 461 if you subtract
one you get two 460 you subtract two you
get two 459 459
- you subtract two from this you get two
350 and this is all about the idea that
the difference doesn't change as long as
you add or subtract the same number to
both and so here we might say that for
hundreds - three hundreds is 100 and
then 59 minus 50 is nine so we would get
the same result the thing to appreciate
is that this is all about subtracting
352 from 461 and that there's multiple
ways of calculating this